hey it's evan i'm a little worked up
tonight and i wanted to
share with you what's going on i
recently brought on a new copywriter
onto my team and i'm really psyched
about her i think she's got mad skills i
think she's going to be able to to
really amp up the copy on the website
and let us have a bigger impact and one
of the first things she's working on is
my whole newsletter campaign sequence so
the first thing she she sent me recently
was
the email confirmation message so this
is the email that you get when you say
you want to join my newsletter but in
order to
get it you gotta click this confirmation
link right pretty simple email
and most people have a really basic
message and
i went off on a really long
philosophical
message to her and probably went way
overkill uh and i didn't you know chew
her out but
the problem here
is most businesses will fail okay 80 of
companies are gonna fail
and i know
i know what it's like
to be there i was making 300 bucks a
month i was i was in a situation where
most people
you know looked at my company and
thought you know wasn't going to take
off and i didn't have the resources
and i didn't have you know the rich
uncle to guide me or the big angel
investor right i i was grinding it out i
was hustling it out
in in a field that
you know i thought was great at the
beginning and realized hey this is way
harder than i thought it was going to be
and i was too afraid and embarrassed to
tell my friends that you know i wasn't
making it wasn't wasn't doing as well as
i thought it would and and i couldn't
afford 20 bucks to go out and have
dinner with them you know
it's hard
and i was one of the guys who got out
you know 80 percent of companies fail 80
of entrepreneurs will fail i made it
through
and i almost gave up many times and
there's
so many moments where it could have gone
the other way you know where it could
have just been one of those numbers
and and luckily somebody or something
saved me and and helped me to keep going
one more day
and now i share that with people
and the newsletter is one of the best
ways that i do it it's not just a
newsletter i don't just jam product down
your throat and say you have to buy this
crappy product that's not going to help
you
it's not just sharing a bunch of stuff
that's on my website hoping people will
visit it's not your normal typical
newsletter i almost hate calling in a
newsletter because that's not what it is
if you could see the comments that come
back every time i send one of these out
it's changing people's lives it's
showing them how to get
get past
that block
when all you see is darkness around you
where you feel like you've tried
everything and nothing is working
i help you get through that because i
had to go through that
so the newsletter is so
critical
and i need that reflected in the message
and and you might think you know an
email confirmation message how stupid is
that how why is ever getting so worked
up about a stupid email confirmation
message why don't you just use a
standard one that comes with your your
your email template
but that's not what i'm about
because if i don't have a great email
confirmation message
i'm going to miss out on being able to
help save some people
and you know what if you are trying to
start a business if you're
not having success if you don't follow
through on the things
something as simple as as clicking
confirm on an email message you know
what that's on you okay that's on you to
follow through on the things that you
said you were gonna do and invest in
yourself to be a better entrepreneur
but it's also on me
it's on me
because i know i can help you i know i
can save your business
and if i don't have a powerful enough
message to get through to people to get
through to you
then that's on me for not doing my best
and so the email confirmation message it
has to reflect this it's not just one
simple email it's everything it's
everything that we do everything i do
has to have that importance has to show
that i can help you
because i've been through it and i
almost gave up and i came out on the
other side and now i know the systems
the tools everything you need to be able
to get your business off the ground and
to the place where you're living a life
that you're happy with
if you know with your business it's the
same thing you should be starting the
business because you have
a powerful ability to help somebody
and you need to make sure that that
message comes across and everything that
you do and everything that you do and
something as simple as an email
confirmation message
it has to come across
because
people are coming to you they have a
problem they don't know how to solve it
and so you have to take them on a
journey
you're going to have to take them to
places that they're not comfortable with
to help them solve this problem
and not everybody's going to want to
take that journey
and as a result they're not going to get
their problems solved they're not going
to live the life that they
deserve to live
and that's on them for making a stupid
choice but it's also on you for not
clearly communicating to that person
why they should take that action and
it's not it's not a sales tool
it's not here's why you need to do this
it shouldn't be salesy at all
it should be powerful it should be
painful it should
should be so obvious that this is the
critical next step for them to take that
you don't need to sell them on anything
and that has to come from a place where
you're so confident in your ability to
help this person
and that if they don't follow through
they're going to make a huge mistake
anyway
it is a simple email and for those of
you watching maybe thinking evan's crazy
evan's going off on on one stupid email
a confirmation newsletter email are you
kidding me but it's true it is
everything
because this is so important that
everything that i do everything that you
do has to have that importance
i didn't ream her out
uh we'll see what she comes back with
she's a great person and i'm looking
forward to having the best
email confirmation
newsletter
message ever
anyway you guys like this video if you
guys have standards if you guys are
really trying to do something to have an
impact leave your mark on this world
let me know what you think leave a
comment below
give it a thumbs up
thank you guys i love
talking to you being with the vent share
my frustration through youtube see you
guys i'll talk to you soon